sophie pour rester dans les prix de
l'esprit des missions la lettre on a eu
envie de te faire un petit cadeau
puisque il y à une personne qui t'a fait
une vidéo qui tu as écrit une lettre
regarde ma demande était le net
non non pourquoi moi bah c'est parce que
j'étais connu en tant que berceau et que
je suis fier de toi a surtout quand il
fait comme ça des émissions le soir
devant tout autant de millions de gens
bon aujourd'hui cj de te recommander une
personne pour l'émission en question est
bon j'ai cherché mais c'est assez vite
trouvé tu vas voir un jeune homme que tu
as peut-être d'ailleurs croisé en
normandie dans le village que nous
connaissons et que nous fréquentons tous
les deux ici tout toi c5 faut que je te
dise il attendait la dernière météo télé
matin pour partir au lycée ensuite il a
attendu le générique c'est au programme
pour aller à la fac il m'a souvent dit
mais sans grand espoir
jusqu'à aujourd'hui est ce que vous
croyez que je pourrai un jour la
rencontre et chercheur troisi me
demander ça
quand j'allais chez le boulanger
aujourd'hui hélas transit ils dénoncent
un artiste sur toi oui c'est ça aussi
est tellement fier de se présenter ou tu
vas voir dans non dans toute sa vérité
je dirai alors après acétate avoir si si
si tu qu'on pu la faire merci à sophie
de ce que tu pourras faire pour lui et
puis nico eu de chance avec une aura la
surprise de sophie davant envoyé par
william leymergie
c'est william qui nous a demandé cette
surprise parce que c'est quelqu'un que
vous connaissez djoudi sophie paraît que
c'est une énorme surprise pour vous et
il ya william leymergie qui vous a écrit
une lettre et un instant qu'ils avaient
une surprise pour vous alors je ne sais
pas du tout c'est lui qui nous a demandé
cette surprise je vous le dis c'est un
garçon qui s'appelle nico et qui est là
ce soir pour vous c'est la surprise de
sophie davant
nico je sais pas qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
non ça va être ça m'étonnerait je vous
jure que c'est vrai il connaît mes goûts
et elle se serait fâché le drôle de goût
faut bien l'avouer mais ça correspond
pas tout à fait convaincu mais ce champ
je voulais dire parce que je pense qu'il
a voulu vous faire
voilà une belle audience et vous les
avez ressenti d'abord je vous jure c'est
pas drôle c'est vraiment lui à
l'héberger qu'assistait îles tonga lui
s'il vous plaît le voeu que ce garçon
bien remplie pour voilà pour ça la mise
et la lettre c'est son cadeau à l'ailé
cheville la nouvelle est tombée ce matin
la nouvelle quand même pour la lettre
merci les eaux je vais voir pour nous